في كل حرب يتم تقسيم المهام يتم تقسيم
الارض الى قطاعات
العراق قام بتقسيم حسب ما اخبرنا الرئيس
بتقسيمها الى يعني اربع قطعات او اربع
مناطق وخلى القياده هاي المناطق مع كل
قائد عسكري قائد سياسي
يتلقى الاوامر من عنده فحسب التقسيم اللي
حضرتك اطلعت عليه نعم الشمال الوسط الجنوب
قسمين القاطع الغربي وكلها الها قياده ضمن
مناطق القتال الميداني بس كنت تفهم منه
انه كان يعتقد انه في جهوزيه عند القوات
العراقيه لكي تقاوم ليس امام يعني ما في
خيار اخر امام القوات العراقيه او القائد
العراقي
يعني ما ممكن تستسلم يعني تقاتل بالقوات
الممكنه مع فارق يعني فارق القوه يعني
الفرق بين ميزان القوه بماذا اخبرك الرئيس
العراقي الراحل عن قتاله شخصيا في شوارع
بغداد القوات الامريكيه وماذا حقق في ذلك
اخبرني انه عند جامعه ام الطبول اعطى
الدبابتين امريكيه
واعترض على هذا السلاح العربي جي 7
المحمول على الكتف واعترض المرحوم الطاهر
في رمضان
على الرئيس قال له هذا تصرفك يعني ما يعني
انت قائد انت مو جندي حتى تقاتل
وبعدها انه لازم تبقى يعني
اوامر وليس ان يعني تترك نفسك لتصاب او
تقتل بالضبط ممكن جندي امريكي
واختل ميزان المعركه